[Musique]
il m'a dit pas assez de chercher tout
est en train de raccourcir mes vacances
alors tu voudrais pas dépêcher un peu ta
pas l'intention de venir avec moi j'y
tiens pas du tout
ses larmes la plus précieuse de notre
nation pas une voiture
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont entraîné les
négociations ont échoué il faut qu'un
agent parte là-bas et ramène le bain
moi c'est vrai ce qui se passe plutôt
deux fois qu'une
c'est pour ça qu'il lui faisait
confiance une mission ça ressemble
plutôt à des vacances des plaques
diplomatiques en kadio georges tu
l'épaule vite fait je sois éblouissant
vous devez former le couple idéal
alors pourquoi l'ont-ils trahi
paul est le divorce est prononcé
tu m'entends mallory la sphère de
barcelone est un fiasco
arrêtez vient-il
soit une dîme aintenant pourquoi tu m'as
trahi soit tu me le dira juste avant que
je te brise l'année
vous devriez être dans le salon de son
père en train de me dire que sa fille a
tué une personne de sang froid
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas fermé l'oeil depuis que tu es
né au monde
baisse la tête et accroche toi
[Applaudissements]
découvrir la vérité j'ai du souci à
faire ça on verra
que savez-vous d'elles était dans les
marines elle ne fait jamais rien sans
motif légitime sera à sa mission la plus
dangereuse
c'est un danger public qu'est ce que tu
as fait j'ai honoré le contrat qu'on m'a
donné
vous n'avez pas quelqu'un a appelé quand
vous avez besoin d aide
[Musique]
léger faites vos prières